your surgeon will perform a skin graft
procedure to repair badly damaged or
missing skin by transplanting healthy
skin to the site of the damaged skin
your skin has three main layers the
epidermis
the dermis
and the hypodermis or subcutaneous layer
containing fat blood vessels and nerves
your skin is your body's largest organ
it serves several major functions
including physically covering your body
protecting the inside of your body
regulating your body temperature and
providing you with your sense of touch
in some cases your skin can become so
damaged that it will not heal properly
your doctor may recommend a skin graft
procedure to repair many skin conditions
including a wound that doesn't heal a
severe burn skin ulcer skin biopsy
a large surgical wound or skin infection
before your procedure you will be given
either general or local anesthesia
if your surgeon is using your own
healthy skin called an autograft
he or she may create a split thickness
skin graft or a full thickness skin
graft depending on the depth of skin
your graft needs to cover
after cleaning the area of healthy skin
called the donor site your surgeon will
use an instrument called a dermatome to
remove very thin slices of your skin
creating a split thickness skin graft
for full thickness skin grafts your
surgeon will use a scalpel to remove all
the layers of skin at the donor site
once your surgeon determines the type of
skin graft you will need he or she will
clean the area of damaged skin and cut
out any dead or unhealthy tissue your
surgeon will place the skin graft on the
wound site and use stitches to keep it
in place
then your surgeon will apply ointment to
the graft and cover it with gauze
finally your surgeon may use bandages to
secure the graft and apply pressure as
the graft adheres to the surrounding
skin
after your procedure your doctor may
give you oral or IV pain medications and
you may need to increase the amount of
calories and protein in your diet to
help your skin heal for the first few
days after your procedure you will need
to carefully protect the skin graft site
you will need to keep the donor site dry
as it heals
you should also avoid strenuous
activities until your doctor tells you
it is safe and you may need to see your
doctor for wound cleaning and bandaging
several times as your wound heals